let me give you some advice you can't
care about anyone else everyone else is
an obstacle
you care what an obstacle wants or feels
you're dead
if i'd cared about anyone or thing i
might have died
you have the talent whether you have the
killer
instinct is the big question
she thought she owned everyone that's
foolish unhinged
well you're fired why are you speaking
i think you licked me but there's
something about poetic
justice that's just so poetic
you won't admit you love me
and so how do you like it
to know you always tell
me get her this doesn't have to be a
scene it really really does
i'd like to remind you all that i'm
doing this in heels
what was your name cruella if you can
i want to make trouble you in i do love
trouble
you have a bit of an extreme side yes
darling
what fun that is
she stole my dogs
[Music]
i guess you must hate her she has made
it me or her
and i choose me
don't worry there's lots more bad things
coming perhaps
[Music]
[Applause]
perhaps
you